the
so we talked about a failed warning as a
Cassandra event and we tried to ask
ourselves in the book why did this
Cassandra event happen we find that
there are four overall factors there is
the quality of the Cassandra herself or
himself then there's the issue itself
and the qualities about the issue that
make a warning relevant to it hard for
people to accept and the last is the
critics the critics of the person giving
the warning the critics of the Cassandra
what do they say and what do they not
say and in those four column headings
the Cassandra the decision-maker the
issue itself and the critics under each
of them there are several different
criteria applying that template to a
potential Cassandra event we think we
can begin to tell who's right and who's
Chicken Little
when we look at the Cassandra herself or
himself that's probably the most
important determinant of whether or not
we have a Cassandra event coming it's
the most important determinant in what
we call the Cassandra coefficient is
that human being because we think what
we're trying to do here is predict the
future not by some algorithm or
artificial intelligence program we think
the solution here to particularly the
future is finding people people who can
do it so what are the qualities of a
cassandra they're an expert they're an
expert in their field and they are
internationally recognized as such this
is not someone waking up in the middle
of the night of the premonition this is
not someone who every year predicts some
other disaster the Cassandra's typically
have never predicted a disaster before
they're experts that never predicted a
disaster before and they are data-driven
usually they run the program that
collects the data
that convinces them and when they look
at the data something pops right out at
them they see through pattern
recognition in a flash they see the
problem that other experts in the field
just don't see or don't understand
so sometimes they see it first and later
people come along and agree with them
but they see it so clearly and then this
other quality of the Kassandra kicks in
and that is necessary to be a Cassandra
and it is the belief in their own
analysis in their own data is so strong
that they feel they must do something
about it they all feel a personal sense
of agency of responsibility they have to
give the warning and when they are not
heeded when they are ignored when they
are ridiculed when in some cases they
are muzzled or fired that creates a
negative feedback loop because they
become more strident or insistent on
getting their message out sometimes
that's off-putting sometimes they are
accused of being obstreperous or
obsessive words like doom and gloom and
all sorts of criticisms are leveled on
them and what we found in the
Cassandra's that we know about and in
some of the ones we think might be
Cassandra's in the future they all had
the same type of criticism these are
people who fit what we learned an
Israeli psychiatrist calls Sentinel
intelligence Sentinel intelligence he
described it is something that is highly
functioning high anxiety people it's not
something that you can learn he thinks
it's something that is innate there the
person who's sitting in the restaurant
or the theater smells smoke first before
anybody else and doesn't just say oh
isn't that all
but they get up and with confidence pull
the fire alarm
second factor in our Cassandra
coefficient is the decision-maker or the
audience one of the problems with these
issues is that frequently there is not a
decision writer or it's a diffuse
decision-making process
it's not clear who can pull the trigger
who can respond to the warning another
characteristic of the decision-maker is
frequently that they have an agenda of
their own they have a position of
responsibility president of the United
States president of the university CEO
of the corporation they assumed that job
with something in mind they were going
to do X Y & Z suddenly somebody comes
into the room and says you can't do that
you can't do your agenda you have to pay
attention to my agenda and oh by the way
paying attention to my agenda is going
to cause you to have to spend money in
ways that you didn't want to spend it
it's going to make life inconvenient for
people decision-makers hearing rat are
very reluctant for the most part because
they are so fixed on their agenda they
don't want to hear about something that
would pull them off from that agenda
decision-makers also in many of these
cases frankly are not experts and not
trained in any way to understand what
the decision-maker is saying in the case
of the Ponzi scheme by Bernie Madoff
Harry Marco Polo's came into the
Securities and Exchange Commission six
times with mathematical formulas and
projections and charts to show the
people at the SEC that Madoff was a
Ponzi scheme
he was a quant he had lots of data he
was talking to lawyers they didn't get
it very frequently the problem is
decision makers don't understand
fundamentally don't understand the
science or the math that the Cassandra
is giving them the issue about which the
Cassandra warns is also very important
in our Cassandra coefficient if the
issue is of such a magnitude that it
would require enormous change session
makers don't usually want to do that if
it's a complex issue people don't
understand it if it's an issue that has
never happened before people find an
excuse for not acting and so sometimes
it's the very fact of the issue itself
that suggests nothing's going to happen
for example one of the ones we're
looking at today is the possibility of
asteroid impact on the earth David
Morrison is our possible Cassandra and
when we ask people what do you think
about the risk a giant asteroid hitting
the earth and destroying a city people
giggle people laugh the issue itself
causes people not to take it seriously
in part because they've seen science
fiction movies with Bruce Willis flying
up into the space and blowing up
asteroids but the issue itself just
seems so ridiculous to them they've
never seen it happen before
but Morrison points out is it has
happened before it's happened a lot in
the history of this planet it just
hasn't happened a lot in the history of
this planet with human beings on it the
last thing we look at to decide if we're
dealing with a possible Cassandra event
last element of our Cassandra
coefficient is the critics of the
Cassandra do the critics take on the
cassandra and say no your data is wrong
you collected the wrong data you
collected the data in the wrong way you
did the wrong kind of analysis on the
data do they have a dialogue among
experts or do they just reject it out of
hand
sometimes the critics are paid critics
as in the case of the tobacco industry
in the United States which bought
experts to say that smoking was not a
problem and perhaps some oil companies
in the past have bought experts to
diminish the threat of global warming so
the question we ask is what is the
critics saying for example in the case
of dr. James Hansen the noted NASA
scientist now at Columbia University who
says that sea-level rise will be much
faster and higher than the UN prediction
but we asked other experts about that
they come up with all sorts of criticism
but they never say his data is wrong and
so when we ask them what's wrong with
Jim Hansen's data they say well he's not
really using the scientific method he's
making leaps of faith back to Hansen
how do you respond to that and he says
if I use the scientific method I would
have to melt Greenland
you want me to melt Greenland repeatedly
to prove that it would change the world
what Hansen says to us is when the data
is so clear that it meets the scientific
method it will be too late we call that
scientific reticence scientific
reticence when scientists are reluctant
to make a conclusion because the data is
not there in the traditional way of
experimentation but what it is they'll
be too late
you